si la guerra iniciada por vladimir putin
en ucrania se traslada cada vez más al
oeste del país este domingo ha sido
bombardeada son unas instalaciones de
una academia militar que se encuentra en
el distrito del vive en el oeste del
país a pocos kilómetros de la ciudad de
libia y también a pocos kilómetros de la
frontera con polonia un país este que es
miembro del año europea y también de la
organización del tratado del atlántico
norte de hecho también en el centro de
la ciudad del vive este domingo nos
hemos despertado nuevamente con las
sirenas antiaéreas que se han vuelto a
disparar en más de una ocasión y también
en una misma ciudad se han oído estas
explosiones
esto ocurre al mismo tiempo de que el
alcalde de la ciudad de iván o francis
que también está en esta zona ha
informado que por segundo día
consecutivo el aeropuerto de su ciudad
ha sufrido un intenso bombardeo y que
hay ambulancias que se están acercando
al lugar una situación que supone una
escalada en la guerra que rusia mantiene
en
con consecuencias que en este momento
son imprevisibles